Everyone to make sourdough bread,
but just totally overwhelmed
with how complicated it seems.
On fermentation.
Banatin basket,
sourdough hydration.
Something. A different language here.
That must have items that you need to make sourdough.
Something to stir your bread with,
something to weigh your dough.
I wouldn't recommend using cups,
because it's not accurate enough.
Some sort of bowl to mix your dough.
Now, whatever.
Starter. Now,
this might seem dolting,
but it's just water and flour
that's fermented. Put a salt.
My water comes out the faucet.
Nasty and full of chlorine.
So I use filtered water.
Flour. I'm using bleach.
Walnut Valley flour,
because I can.
You don't need to buy fancy flowers
when you first starting out.
And this is the flower I have right home right now.
So that's what I'm gonna use.
I'm gonna 0 it out,
and I'm gonna make sure we're in ground.
I'm gonna measure 650 grams of water.
The dog hair in here.
Life was just dog hair.
Then I put 200 grams of starter in there.
This is my sourdough starter.
Smells like paint stripper,
and it's nice and bubbly.
People will say that you use.
You need to use sourdough starter.
At its peak. Um,
I've used sourdough starter.
Out the fridge.
Has been sitting in the fridge for four or five days.
I've used sourdough starter ice bag.
Just an hour before.
I've used sourdough starter.
That I haven't felt for a few days.
And just sitting
Out on the counter.
Um, to me, it hasn't really made that much difference.
You just need a.
An established sourdough starter.
2:11, 2:12. As I said,
I'm not trying to get it as close as possible,
but it's. It's fine.
It's gonna be okay.
Now I'm just gonna mix this up a little bit
just to incorporate the sourdough starter in this.
I just remembered that I'm using a bowl of
way too small,
cause I'm doubling the recipe.
I'm actually double in the back
to making two lives.
So I always make two lives at once.
And I don't know why I grabbed this bowl for this.
450 grams of flour from here,
9:56. I put a little bit too much water,
a little bit too much starter on it,
so that should be working.
The 20 grams of salt. Oh,
the salt in. 20 grams,
21 grams, 22 grams.
But I never got it just perfect, so.
And then we're gonna mix.
Mix the salt in on top
right there.
And this is the part where
a lot of people use their hands.
I can absolutely
cannot stand having dough under my fingernails
and in my hands.
It's just something I just
really don't enjoy. So, see, wow.
This is the consistency you're gonna get
with just mixing it,
like with the stick thing, spatula.
And that's about the same as
you're gonna get with your hands.
You do not need to put your fingers in here. This.
If you leave this on the counter
or you leave this in the sink to wash later,
this is gonna turn into concrete.
The salad I mix,
so I put on this,
the dough is gonna Harden,
and it's gonna be horrible to get it off.
So I'm gonna rinse this off.
I'm gonna cover this with an olive flour sack.
Now Joanna gangsters pour out her Magnolia line.
Hurry up. I bought this. That's all.
Doesn't have to be airtight.
It stops the dough.
Anything from getting into the dough,
and it stops the dough from
kind of getting a hard skin on the top.
Now we're gonna do the stretch and fold.
This part is super easy.
Do not be intimidated.
I'm gonna use wet hands
so the dough doesn't stick to my fingers.
Scoop around the side,
and I'm just gonna lift it up and pull it back down.
Normally use two hands for this,
but baby on my lap.
Then we just gonna keep doing that
every 30 minutes,
three to four times.
Never stretch and folded four times.
I think the most I've ever done is three.
I'm only do two,
and it's normally at least
an hour between stretching and folding.
The lazy way I like to do it is start making my dough
as after I cook dinner
and I'm about to start getting the kids ready for bed,
I make my dough,
let it sit, and as I'm putting the kids To bed,
getting their bags,
whatever I'm doing.
I'm coming into the kitchen,
stretching and folding.
Then before I get ready for bed,
I might remember to do one last stretch and fold.
And then I will leave it covered like this overnight.
Now, when I wake up in the morning,
it will be ready.
It will be arisen.
It would have been.
It's both ferment
and it will be ready to shape and put into baskets
or smaller bowls
or whatever you wanna use.
Shape it ready to bake.
Thanks for that.
You just. Thanks.
At this point,
the dough is starting to get really smooth,
so I can get a really good stretch.
Now we'll leave it to bulk for men,
and we'll be back.
Fast forward the next morning.
And now I'm shaping
and getting the dough ready to put in the baskets.
Here, I'm kinda tucking the dough underneath itself
and pulling it towards me.
And this gives the top nice and tight,
which helps with the ride.
This is a basket I actually got from target, and, like,
the dollar section,
I got three of them for, like, $4, I think.
And I really like this for shaping dough.
Then I'm gonna just wrap this up in this
flour stack towel and put it in the fridge.
I'm gonna leave this in there for at least a day,
and it'll be risen
ready for me to bake. This one,
I'm gonna put in this cute Basket I got from IKEA.
I really like this basket,
and I wanna let this one sit on the counter for, like,
four hours until it's risen and ready to bake.
Now, I'm gonna use a preheated Dutch oven.
This one's a speciality one for bread,
but you can use any regular Dutch oven.
Just use Parchment paper
if you use a regular Dutch oven as this deep
and it's easy to get it out.
There she is.
Lazy sourdough bread.